hello folks
welcome to rational science directly
from germany frankfurt germany
um we're going to have a question and
answer at the end of the
lecture
but uh today i think i'm going to be
skipping the extinction part because
there's really no news out there okay i
mean uh covet is over right
and the war in ukraine is over and right
now they have is just you know this
bombing of cities
and more sanctions and counter sanctions
we just have to wait
what happens with all of that
instead i'm going to get directly into
something that happened this week a
fellow
made a video of my science series
and he addressed each one of the videos
each one of the points
and i commend him for that he went in
there and analyzed each point from his
point of view obviously right
and i think more people should be doing
that
not necessarily with me but
with their teachers i mean if you have
instructors or teachers in college or
school or high school or whatever i
think you should put them on the spot
see from how much they know if they can
defend their positions okay and that's i
think uh good for
morale in science
you need that okay anyways uh he uh
addressed uh almost every point
i think he addressed them all in fact
and um
one of the issues there is that
you know he said that he's not a
scientist or that he's not a physicist
okay
and we don't hold that against him here
i mean under no circumstance we don't
care he's got a phd or he's just got a
high school we don't care okay
uh we're going to look at his arguments
okay that's important here at least
and so we don't care if he's got a nobel
prize or he just came out of school
that's one issue the other one is that
you know he since he addressed each one
of the issues
uh that i raised in my videos uh you
know there's no way i can have one
lecture with all that
you know to address each one of those
points so i'm going to be doing that
over the next few weeks i was going to
be addressing those same topics in one
way or another in the next few weeks
anyways because that's why i was making
the science series okay so in a way it's
it comes in very handy to use his video
uh as a uh you know as a guide
and one of the issues there is that you
know
this fellow represents
as far as i'm concerned i mean i've been
in this for 25 years now
and i've heard it all okay and i can
tell you one thing this fellow
has the same idea that 99 of the people
out there have
uh and what i call misconceptions of
science misconceptions of physics
and those i want to address but it's
good because he is the typical case
for what people usually think out there
what people say out there so he's he's a
perfect case for this
anyways
the issues i'll be addressing in the
coming weeks okay i want you to put it
in the right context so that you're
aware those who want to follow the
series okay
and i'm going to be
looking at what is science about what is
physics about okay
i'm going to compare the scientific
method versus what i call the
mathematical method okay what's the
mathematical mathematical method it's
what we have today
and that we've had now for 400 years
okay that's essentially what i'm going
to call the mathematical method why do i
call it mathematical because they do
everything by magic
magic
what is black magic
when you move concepts around
you transfer energy
you wave the wave
you vibrate the field
and there are no such physical objects
in physics
okay so we're going to distinguish
objects from concepts as you can see
there at the bottom we need to know what
a difference is between an object and a
concept
and
that's
90 of the problem there as i like to say
uh the definition of the word object
destroys all religions
and i'm going to look at explain versus
describe another big major problem
people don't understand the difference
between an explanation and a description
a lot of people think that an
explanation is just a bunch of
descriptions a series of descriptions
okay big difference between an
explanation a description but few people
can tell them apart and so we need to
clarify that one
theory versus hypothesis big issue there
also
people don't understand the difference
the establishment has brainwashed
everyone to think that a hypothesis is
an unproven theory and a tentative
explanation
no that's not what a hypothesis is at
all okay we're gonna address that
and uh then we're gonna look at rational
versus irrational because people
everybody wants to think of themselves
as rational
and we're going to show that no we
define what rational is what irrational
is and then whoever meets those criteria
is either rational or irrational okay so
we go by definitions
and uh so what are we going to be
addressing specifically well here you
have it uh these are the invisible
intangible mechanisms objects uh things
out there that the mathematical
establishment has never been able to
address never been able to answer
okay and so they
invoke gravity you know nobody can
understand in mathematical physics right
nobody can understand what causes
gravity how it's caused how mother
nature does it they can tell you how it
does how it moves like you know the the
acceleration that sort of thing but they
can't tell you the cause how does mother
nature perform this magic trick that's
what they cannot explain
uh so the mechanisms that's what we're
looking at magnetism how does a magnet
attract another they don't have an
explanation for that people think they
have but
again they just they confuse description
with explanation
and uh electricity uh they have no idea
how electricity works mainly because
they don't know what the
uh an atom looks like which is the next
one there atomic architecture behavior
they have this little bead rolling
around the nucleus and the only answer
they have to give there is
uh why doesn't the electron fly out of
the atom
like why does the earth fly out of the
solar system same thing here if the
electron is a little bead that goes
around or is somewhere around the proton
the question is why does it
spontaneously fly away or fall into the
nucleus and if you cannot explain that
you do not have an explanation for
electricity because electricity today is
defined as the flow a lot of electron
beads so we have a problem with
electricity if the atom that they're
basing it on is bunk
okay and then light of course uh you
know you need to understand
uh
what
physical entity mediates light
and why are these important invisible
and intangible because we we figured out
pretty much you know all the visible
stuff
you ask a kid
you know how did the cart
move from a to b
okay
and he says very simple i attached the
car to a horse
and a horse pulled it and that's how it
went from a to b
and we all look at that
if he shows us a movie of that right or
even with his explanation and we all
understand it
we understand it why because we see all
the objects
okay we see everything there in front of
us we see the cart we see the rains we
see the uh horse and we see it moving we
see the movie of that and we all
understand it just by looking you don't
need to go to the university you need
you do not need to understand
mathematics
all you need to understand is how that
cart moved from a to b and a 10 year old
can tell you that
okay
and so what's the issue the issue is
that
you know
all these invisible intangible entities
what's the problem or
mechanisms or phenomena the problem
there is you cannot see the mediator
that's the that's the whole problem
you know here here you have the pen okay
we let go of it falls to the floor right
and you don't see anything here you
don't see anything here you can't touch
anything here or there
so people conclude that there's nothing
there
gravity is done by
magic
and we're going to say the argument is
going to be that there is something
there
you just can't see it or touch it but
there is something there
that is in contact with the skin of the
pen
and people say bill you're crazy
what do you mean i don't see anything i
don't touch it yet because you're using
c touch
the definition of the word object that
which has shape
so what's there what's
here or here
has shape
but you can't see or touch it
and you say what kind of shape does it
have i can't see her touch it well shape
is unrelated to see and touch that's the
issue
anyways i'm going to get into that later
on in
in in the coming weeks but the point
here is and
you if you're going to be doing
gravity if you're going to be doing
light if you're going to be doing
electricity magnetism without an a
mediator
you're using black magic
and that's what mathematical physics has
that's why we call it math and
physics they do it with black magic they
do it with concepts not with objects
okay so that's the issue
okay so
here we have a
rundown of what mathematical method is
which is the one that i'm going to be
addressing attacking okay analyzing
okay and essentially
the big problem is that this is not a
scientific method what this is is just a
method of research and persuasion
and to give people something to do you
know to study as they call it and
studying is not science science is
explaining this tell me something that
came out of all that work if nothing
comes out of that work you're not doing
science
and so what these people do is just uh
you know the so-called method that we
inherited from the 17th century
so-called scientific that's with
quotations right scientific revolution
is uh is this you know it consists of um
you observe something or someone
observes something right
uh you give it a tentative explanation
known as a hypothesis
and that's really not true because
mathematical physics doesn't rely on
explanations at all as i showed
in other videos you know you have these
people saying that science doesn't
explain meaning mathematics doesn't
explain mathematics describes so no they
don't do explanation but they call them
explanations because again people think
that explanations are just a bunch of a
series of descriptions okay but that's
what they call a hypothesis a tentative
explanation okay then they do a
prediction they say okay let me
figure out and see if i understood if my
theory or my tentative theory is correct
and i'm gonna
make a prediction to see if that's what
happens when i put it under certain
conditions and then you do an experiment
meaning you're going to do some
measurement you describe it
mathematically after you take some data
and some numbers there and then you
describe it mathematically you know
perhaps with an equation so that's just
a description so far you haven't
explained anything okay
uh
they do
they invent technology and they think
that technology is proof of
uh theories
uh you'll hear a lot of people out there
just parrot and say it over and over
again because all they never even
thought what they're saying about what
they're saying and it's a gps
proves that general relativity is
correct and computers prove that quantum
mechanics is correct because you
wouldn't have a computer it wouldn't
work if it weren't for quantum mechanics
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
and again it shows the irrationality of
all these people okay the gps prove that
time is a physical object
that you can warp that you can bend like
a banana
does a computer prove that a particle
can be at two places at once
because those are the explanations they
give you
and you say well if that weren't true
the computer wouldn't work
the computer works because of trial and
error that's how
technology is made or like mr uh thomas
edison said you know i haven't failed
i just found ten thousand ways that
don't work he just tried one thing after
another until he got it right
did edison need to know what a field is
or what electricity is
obviously not in the 19th century all he
did was try things
until he got it right that's how
technology works has nothing at all to
do with the explanation the theory of
how it works out there in the world of
invisible world of mother nature father
universe or whoever
okay so this is the issue and uh so
people say they think that technology
has something to do with science it does
not
technology is
uh
producing a gadget by trial and error
science is explaining
you know how the universe works how
gravity works how electricity or
magnetism work that's what science is
that's what uh
physics is
uh then what they do is they go around
persuading people okay to convince them
to give them a prize or you know to
grant them something maybe money or a
good position somewhere
and um
someone you know they vote for it and
they say well if it's you got 50 plus
one then it becomes truth
becomes a theory okay and uh from theory
goes to proof and truth and fact that's
the way they work in mathematics and uh
those who are on the losing end they say
oh i'm gonna verify his his reading i'm
gonna verify his experiment see if it's
what he collected all that information
is correct and so they do have
verification what is called
falsification falsifying
okay
austrian fellow there who came up with
all that nonsense
and they finally went in a ward and
you know medals and so on so that they
uh have authority you know you win a
noble then you can trash anyone on earth
because you know who are you
i've got a noble what do you have you
know
it's that kind of thing
okay um and so here uh you see the
the what we propose in exchange we're
saying this is the rational
scientific method this is what science
really is
it's rational explanations and we that's
why we're gonna have to work on the word
rational and the word explanation okay
those two words we need to understand
very well in order to understand what
science is
but the scientific method is a way of
explaining to someone else a mechanism
in the case of physics obviously we do
physics here okay and what is a
hypothesis nothing to do with a theory
nothing to do with an explanation
hypothesis are the objects the
definitions and the initial scene with
which you start your theory you have to
start the movie of your theory your
explanation somewhere okay and this is
essentially the
the objects are you know what objects
are you gonna use in your theory what
definitions are you gonna use are they
solid you know are they irrational et
cetera
and then you know
what is known as a statement of the
facts you have to base your theory on
the initial scenes you know if your
theory your explanation doesn't follow
from the initial scenes then you have an
irrationality you know i mean
hopefully the theory follows from your
initial assumptions and then the theory
is the mechanisms and the causes okay
what caused something to happen what is
the mechanism that mother nature uses
out there and again we're looking at the
invisible stuff because all the visible
stuff we've already figured out what we
haven't figured out or the
mathematicians haven't figured out are
the invisible stuff that's what we're
going to be looking at okay
and then where yeah we have the uh coral
areas at the end uh i'm not going to go
over that too much okay
okay so what does this fellow say well
he uh he
made a couple statements from the start
in his video
and it just blew me away
i'm saying my god how can we
you know uh
be so different you know and and this is
what he said okay that's how he starts
his presentation give me a second here
and i'll get it started all right
pay attention please okay here it goes
the issue and argument raised in this
rejoinder is
the mathematical method has done well
over the last 400 years since the
mathematics revolution
the scientific method has worked pretty
well so far since its inception we've
managed to find out quite a bit about
the universe especially over the last
couple hundred years
okay
now when i heard that
i didn't need to go any further because
he already said a mouthful there
first thing thought that came to mind is
you know i'm from planet earth
what planet are you from
please take me to your leader
maybe i'm in the wrong planet i don't
know it could be that i'm in the wrong
planet and i need to find out maybe i
went to the land of the klingons maybe i
went uh a time travel to the future
maybe to kill my granddaughter before
she comes back to the past he kills me
first you know
with general relativity you never know
you know uh so the question is which one
of us is on the right planet uh
have we
had success with science
has it gotten better over time
especially in the last 200 years
well i see it exactly in reverse
i'm saying that we have made no progress
in the last 2 500 years since the days
of the greek at least right
and in the last 200 years more like 150
years last 150 years we went backwards
we got we got worse we have more and
more irrational explanations for common
phenomena we don't have
rational explanations
and so this fellow says we made progress
i'm saying we have not made progress one
of them one of us is on the wrong planet
okay it could be me okay that's what
we're gonna find out
okay so um let me show you some
irrationalities that i just kind of
brainstorm
uh
so as to guide today's lecture okay uh
that just came popped into my head uh
some of them have to do with what i've
been covering in the last couple weeks
okay so uh
those who stuck around you'll you'll
realize you'll you'll see what i'm
talking about here you know
i'm covering some of the old ground
and serves as a uh summary for the month
of march anyways and here's a all the
irrationalities that are rampant in
mathematical physics now this this is a
very small list i could tell you i could
go on and on and on and on i've got to
list this long okay but um
this is a good place to start i mean
this fella says that we have rational
explanations i guess he's thinking about
or that science is doing fine especially
the last 200 years and i'm saying you
know right now we have something called
dark matter out there dark energy
and those are two irrationalities
complete irrational
nonsense poppycock okay and here let me
show you an example of that here's a the
balloon analogy that i covered a couple
weeks ago again
okay and dark matter is on the inside
pulling the universe inwards and we have
the dark energy you know kind of like
the anti-gravity pushing the space
outwards okay and all the galaxies are
really stuck to the edge to the surface
of the balloon so as the balloon grows
the theory is that all the galaxies fly
apart and that's why the
universe is flying apart according to
mathematical physics right before our
very eyes
and the first question that a irrational
individual asks is what's the what's the
white stuff that's what we want to
understand
and that's an answer you won't find and
they won't give you and they say okay
it's an unscientific question you cannot
ask
you know what is uh
what is the white uh stuff out there
and you know it's like asking they say
it's like asking what's north of the
north pole
well you know north of the north pole
you have polaris uh there's a star there
and beyond that you have galaxies and
stars and asteroids and what have you
you know so so
there is stuff north of the north pole
so that's a terrible analogy or a
terrible answer who someone invented in
everyone else's parents without even
thinking what they're saying
and the question here is that that white
stuff gives
contour to that balloon which is space
the balloon is space so they're treating
space as a physical object because again
an object is that which has shape and
what we're staring at is that which has
shape
so whenever you have shape you have to
have something giving it contour you
have to answer what is the white stuff
and it turns out that that little um
white stuff is the one they can't answer
just by sheer coincidence okay
and yeah that that is suspicious you
know they allude the question that we
want answered okay
and here you have um
another version of what dark matter is i
covered that again a couple weeks ago
but let's go over real quickly
over it
you see a couple galaxies on your right
side there one on top one on the bottom
and what we show there is one star which
has a certain radius from the center of
the galaxy and another one has a longer
radius in other words it's farther out
and what the mathematicians the
astronomers out there
eventually concluded is that the ones on
the outside travel at the same speed or
faster than the ones on the inside and
that's counterintuitive because you know
like that would be like pluto traveling
faster than mercury around the sun
that's essentially what you're staring
at there
and so how do they come up with this
dark matter which is that uh halo that
you see around each galaxy okay i made
it visible
okay and and you know i direct your
attention to the bottom of the bottom
left of the screen area where you see
that little equation now you don't have
to have any math to understand what i'm
going to because i just i'm looking at
this from a conceptual point of view you
have that little v which is velocity we
don't care about the square because
again we're looking at it conceptually
and you see the big r which is uh the
radius and the issue is as r gets bigger
and bigger and bigger okay the radius
gets bigger and bigger in a galaxy in
other words the star is farther and
farther away from the center of the
galaxy
the little v there the
one with velocity squared the little v
is getting bigger
and you say how can that be it's totally
contrary to what the equations tells you
it should be the other way around if r
goes big then the v should go
smaller
and what they've done is to compensate
for that they invented this variable
called dark matter
dark matter is just a bunch of mass
artificial mass that they put in the
equation to compensate actually over
compensate
to make sure that the velocity matches
what they see what the astronomers see
out there in the night sky that's the
issue okay so dark matter is a variable
and they turn this variable into a
physical object into particles
okay and now they're searching for them
and they're saying well what else could
it be
and yes we have a different explanation
for that
you know i've talked about that in the
past several times so i'm not going to
cover it here but the point is
these people have a variable which they
turn into particles
mass
you know which they needed to compensate
for the extra radius so that the
velocity matches what the astronomers
see out there
and so it's a mathematical contraption
nothing but but since they can't think
of any other mechanism they say we
proved it there is
dark matter out there
and that's the majority of the
mathematicians there are others who
go with monde you know modified
newtonian and a couple other people are
searching for other intermediaries
they're uh between one and the other but
essentially they're looking for mass
they say the only way we can explain
that is with mass
and it turns out you know dark matter
according to our theory has nothing at
all to do with mass okay nothing
okay so uh
that's uh dark matter and dark energy
uh black hole i mean how irrational can
you get other than the black hole this
person says we've done a lot of progress
in the last 200 years
what we invented in the last 200 years
at least 150 years since einstein
uh well einstein never believed in black
holes but i mean you know you had all
these other people who
took einstein's equations they turned
them into a black hole and today we have
this monster called black hole and it's
an irrational entity only
dum-dums you know believe in black holes
and you say why is it an irrational
entity
well very simple i mean
it's a no-brainer
okay there is no such thing as a black
hole because a black hole is zero
dimensional
zero size
and has no matter in it
and mass is the quantity of matter if i
remember correctly from high school
long time ago okay so give me a second
here
uh it's the quantity of matter a measure
of a quantity of matter of course and if
it's got no matter it's got no mass
and so let's see zero dimensional
no volume no size
no mass no matter
looks like you're talking about nothing
and they say this nothing called a black
hole moves stars around and sucks the
skin you know their gaseous skin from
the star
so yeah we have an irrationality and
these people just oh
they proved that they they even took a
picture of it
[Laughter]
okay so uh we got a problem because
these people don't understand that a
black hole is zero dimensional
no size no nothing
they don't understand that and they said
bill you're crazy what do you mean it's
no sign i mean i have several people who
told me that they said you know
no one says that a black hole has zero
size and uh
no no volume no dimensions
no matter meaning no mass where did you
get this bill
okay so let's put
evidence proof right that's what these
people believe in right authority above
all authority i mean some of you know a
guy named stephen hawking
he was a british
mathematician mathematical physics died
a few years ago
and uh he wrote a book a famous book
called a brief history of time
and you know some of you might be aware
of that book i guess if you've been in
the industry of physics right you should
know something about stephen hawking
this is what hawking has to say this is
not me okay this is you can check it out
for yourself verified on your own you
don't have to trust my word here okay
and here it is okay this is what good
old
stevie says
okay he's talking about chandra sakhar
who worked for arthur eddington
and got a nobel prize and so he's
explaining how chandrasekhar
indian fellow
won his nobel prize and he wanted for
proving
proving
with math mathematics right
doing mathematics uh equations that can
sign a thing right proving that a black
hole is zero dimensional here it is
calculated that that a cold star more
than about one and a half times mass of
the sun would not be able to re support
itself against its own gravity would it
collapse to infinite density infinite
density ring a bell
eddington was shocked by that
implication and he refused to believe
chandrasekhar's results eddington
thought it was simply
not possible that what
that a star could collapse to a point
meaning what did einstein say einstein
himself wrote a paper in which he
claimed that stars would not shrink to
zero
size
let me say that again you probably
didn't hear it zero size that's not me
saying it that's
stevie there okay
however he was awarded the nobel prize
in 1983 for his early work on limiting
massive cold stars chandrasekhar had
shown that the exclusion principle right
quantum mechanics
could not halt the collapse of a star
more massive than the chandrasekhar
limit
zero size you say well must have been a
typo
okay so let's go to his other uh part of
the
book his book
says the following as penrose showed
penrose you know uh
also who just won a nobel prize a couple
i think last year showed that a star
collapsing under its own gravity is
trapped in a region whose surface
eventually shrinks to
zero
size so we have all these people proving
zero size
uh
black holes singularities okay
and since the surface of the region
shrinks to zero so too must its volume
all the matter in the star will be
compressed into a region of
zero volume
is anybody hearing me uh i'm talking
about zeros here okay zero size zero
volume in other words one has a
singularity contained within a region of
space-time known as a black hole
okay now uh
this is not me i didn't invent this okay
you can find it in the book i put the
pages there so you can check it out on
your own because a lot of people say
bill you're crazy what are you talking
about zero size yeah zero size black
hole is zero size why would a why would
a black hole a star right that's
collapsing on it because of its own
gravity why would it stop that you know
greater than zero
what what would be the mechanism of
stopping right there so that you can say
well there's still something there a lot
of mass compressed into a little tiny
thing
no it's not infinitesimal it's zero okay
let's make sure we understand it black
hole is zero side there is no such thing
as a black hole okay and you say well
bill that's only one source okay let's
put another one just to make sure that
we have all the evidence on the table
this fellow he's a fellow over there in
cambridge and cambridge university press
published his book he was a professor
for several years i think he still is on
solving the equation with a particular
value row of central density you will
get a model of a star with
mass m
and radius r okay
plot r as a function of m and show that
r
falls to zero radius falls to zero zero
radius okay i hope you understand when m
is equal to chandrasekhar mass
if you can do all these then you have
repeated the calculation for which
chandrasekhar won the nobel prize
i hope you understood some of that you
know we're talking about zero zero zero
zero there's nothing there
and let me rub it in just while we're at
it okay here we have two fellows
professor cole miller university of
maryland and professor david harrison
from the university of toronto black
holes are the most exotic objects in the
universe a black hole is a region of
space the matter that forms a black hole
is crushed out of existence there is
nothing there
okay i hope uh that
struck a bell somewhere okay what does
harrison say an object whose
gravitational pressure is so intense
that the matter of the object is crushed
out of existence
okay so we have no matter okay
and we have no uh
size
no volume
no dimensions
okay so the question is um
what do we have
what are we talking about you know
what's left
and so here it is as far as i know mass
is a measure of quantity of matter or
you need something related to matter to
have mass
i think so okay well here we have it
okay we have all these posts the
dictionary the wikipedia all they say
although all of them say the same thing
mass is a measure how much matter an
object contains turns out a black hole
uh crushes all matter out of existence
okay
and so if mass is the quantity of matter
and the black hole crushes it matter all
out of existence we have no mass
whatsoever according to the definitions
of mathematical physics
so so far we have absolutely nothing in
front of us
okay
so no there is no such thing as a black
hole because a black hole by definition
is nothing
they defined nothing
and then they took a picture of it and
they showed it to the world and they
showed a
drain there with water going around they
said well the black hole is is you can't
see it there is is that a black hole
the picture you took no that's matter
rushing into a black hole
so where's the black hole what's the
zero dimensional singularity that has no
size that's in the center of that
okay
so that's how they sell these things and
people just buy it because they don't
understand anything they don't question
anything coming from the mathematical
establishment
okay how about uh big bang there we have
uh next one down on the list uh here we
have big bang okay and i showed this the
other day okay our universe according to
mathematics space time and matter are
all in there so we have space time and
matter inside that uh
tilted glass that's pouring beer out
makes me thirsty okay
anyways uh so we had uh all these years
we have uh
this thing it's been around for almost
14 billion years okay it's called
the
space time the
the
blocked universe whatever and the
question is how did this start
how did the first
bit of matter
start and the way they calculate or the
way they figure this theory out is they
said look we figured out in the 1930s
1929 1930s that all galaxies are
expanding are flying away from each
other
okay so the world is exploding they say
we got it we understand this what's
happening is yesterday we're closer
together and even before yesterday they
were even closer together
so if you take run the movie backwards
what you have is
all matter condensing into a little
point a singularity and you say well
where did the singularity come from
i mean can you tell me that and they say
well no that's unscientific to ask that
question we don't know see the theory
stops at frame number two of the film
and i showed
the other day here it is
that's uh that's the movie of the big
bang you know it starts at frame number
two it doesn't go to frame number one
where the singularity is created they
say we don't know what happened there we
can't explain it it's unscientific
because we have no way of proving uh
blah blah blah blah blah and essentially
what they're saying is we cannot explain
the mechanism of how something comes
into existence from nothing that's
essentially the problem and uh that's
when the religious folk you know they
look at them and say ah they smirk and
they say ah you just don't want to say
that it's god who made all this stuff
right that's all your problem
and yeah this is this is the issue in in
that sense i gotta side with the
religious folk the traditional religion
uh because they've got the right idea
you know why did you stop frame number
two and say well we started the
singularity
well how convenient i mean when did you
start at you know before the singularity
what happens another answer they give
you is like i said you know when i
analyzed uh some of the religious folk
like saint augustine and saint anselm
and
uh saint thomas aquinas you know and
they all had this idea that god is
outside of time he got made time you
know
he made all the time he could
and so he made time so he's outside of
time and these people are more or less
saying the same thing that time began
with the singularity and so the
religious folks americans say
we know what you're trying to say you're
trying to avoid god all you atheists
right
yeah they're right they're totally right
that's that's the issue they're trying
to avoid you know
god god god made the singularity and the
question is um you know they say well we
don't need god and that's fine you don't
need god but then you have to have an
explanation of how the singularity came
to be
you can't avoid that you can't sidestep
that question by sidestepping it ruins
your entire theory your theory is bunk
you cannot say the galaxy going back and
back and back until we reach frame
number two
if you can't take it to frame number one
you don't have a rational theory because
that's the issue the issues how did
something come in from nothing can you
explain that
and they do have
i don't know if you can call it an
explanation
uh an excuse
that's probably a little better and here
it is okay this is what it looks like
and it's uh
it's a um
what's my call it's uh someone asked the
question quora and uh phd answered the
question
and it's how this question was answered
that's important okay
and which answers the question of how
the universe came to be how matter came
in to be okay and here it is says is it
true that in quantum mechanics particles
can appear and disappear seemingly from
nowhere or without a cause
and a phd this is a phd okay he answers
qm obeys physical law not magic oh okay
good thank god
and says yes the way things behave at
the quantum level is often weird and
very non-intuitive
bad way to start a presentation he's
going to say that it's counterintuitive
okay i guess
we're heading into irrationality here
and you and yes during high energy
collisions all sorts of particles can
appear disappear
out of the vacuum that we're not even
there to begin with
okay sounds like magic
but again all this goes according to
well-established theory quantum field
theory not magic
[Laughter]
so uh that's just a statement these
people are doing magic and saying oh no
ours is not magic magic was what the
traditional religions did we don't do
magic
and so you see where the problem is
these people are doing magic they're
saying it's science
and so yeah this fellow
he was educated with all this stuff you
know time dilation some of the others
there i'm not going to go over all those
but he was educated with all the stuff
he
or
read about him i guess
and um
he just accepted it at face value on the
basis of authority
you know the mathematical physicists the
scientists
they fed it to the world and he said
well they can't all be wrong i mean
the guys in
cambridge the the ones in
harvard the ones in caltech the chinese
the russians all these people are wrong
bill
they're not wrong they're all irrational
because they don't care about mechanisms
that's why they're irrational they give
you a bogus physical interpretation
saying well we moved the energy in this
direction we moved the field over there
and then the mass was kicked out in that
other direction so they talk about all
these concepts and people say whoa
that's
over my head i guess you know because
all you mathematicians know all those
equations and you talk about mass and
all the stuff we don't understand so you
must be right
and essentially it amounts to what
happened in the middle ages where
the only person in the village who could
read was the priest and so he would tell
them what the bible said and everybody
else had just to accept whether they
liked what they were hearing or not they
had to accept it because the only guy
who could read was the priest and we
have these priests a modern day priests
are the mathematicians you know
they've been handed this um
the
mathematical world
and people say well i don't understand
all that stuff so i'm just going to rely
on what he says and when all the
mathematicians say we all agree you know
space-time black holes uh dark matter
particle at two places at once people
say well it must be true because they
can't all be wrong
so it's an issue of authority nothing
but okay
if they're all irrational they're all
flat earthers we're all screwed okay
that's the issue
okay so uh here's an example okay
uh it's famous space time okay
and uh you have two versions of space
and you have the ridiculous 2d space
time and a ridiculous 3d space time and
you can see that uh what is sitting on
top of space time the other one has is
drawing space time towards the center in
this case the earth right
and the question is these two cannot
both be right
and so these people put these things out
there and they get thousands of hits and
people say oh and on oh that's so great
that's so fantastic and they don't even
know what they're staring at they don't
even know if this matches in any way
you know what einstein said
and it turns out that they don't because
einstein first of all said that you know
you can only apply relativity out there
and a lot of these folks don't know it
you know there's this fellow who uh goes
out there and um says that he's gonna
prove warped space in his basement
and he goes in there he does the
cavendish experiment in his basement he
says oh i proved uh that you know that
let me put this out of here for a second
and
i i proved warp space in my basement
no you can't
space-time doesn't work down here i
can't i can't explain using einstein's
equations okay i cannot explain why this
pencil this pen
drops to the table i cannot explain it
with i cannot
do i cannot apply einstein's equation
here you can only apply einstein's
equation with big masses out there in
the global universe
you cannot you cannot say that space is
so warp here that this falls at that
rate that that's why it's falling
okay and so again these people have
these notions let me get it back up here
now
okay
and one guy says 3d spacetime no that's
not what einstein said so so this guy
thinks he's very smart because he said
oh i figured out how space-time really
works no space-time works like the one
on the left for otherwise mercury's
orbit which is up there in the center
uh wouldn't work
you know mercury's orbit the one
einstein applied his theory to works
like the 2d space time the ridiculous 2d
space time on the left the
two-dimensional one
okay so which one should you choose
should you go with one on the right
which is a totally different mechanism
than the one on the left that's the
million dollar question well you know
i'm a guy who believes in authority and
uh
and in
[Music]
what is democracy people who vote
majority rule
everybody votes for flat earth i'll be a
flat earther then okay i got to be a
flat earther because majority rules
right and so i'm going to go with the
head honchos
of mathematical physics and here we have
one his name is brian greene and this is
his version which is the one on the left
that you just saw
okay that's his version of why the moon
doesn't fly out of the solar system very
straightforward okay we have a
depression
you know this uh surrealistic depression
a two-dimensional cross-section of
space-time i guess and the moon doesn't
fly away because it is trapped within
that depression like a little ball
rolling around a roulette okay so
i don't know what part you didn't
understand there because it's very
straightforward it's illustrated and he
brian green uh he's a
phd right a celebrity etc etc okay so he
should know okay so you got to follow
him because
he's you know he he knows his stuff he's
done all that math he should know
whether the earth
or the moon rolls around
you know a depression caused by the
earth or whether it's
being pointed towards the center of the
earth and to the center of the moon into
the center of the sun
which way does uh
the space-time gravity work
okay so you so you got to figure out
which of the two those two can't be both
right okay
and just to get to rub it in i'm gonna
go also with another source which is
also um
authoritative okay so here it is that's
nasa nasa also has the earth weighing
down the canvas not uh the canvas uh
being dragged into the center of the
earth
okay so we have to go with this version
of gravity according to einstein
according to
the folks in nasa and all the phds out
there right who do with do um
mathematical physics we have to go with
their version and not to the
people who
you know think they invented something
new by pointing the plane by drawing the
fish net inside the earth okay
okay so what is the mechanism why
doesn't the earth fly out of the solar
system why doesn't the moon fly out of
the earth orbit
okay what's keeping it there and here we
have it okay this is this is what the
theory says
the irrational theory of
math of uh general relativity says here
it is okay this is the curve wall of
time they say time is a physical object
like a wall the earth
rolls around or slides along this curve
and that's why it doesn't fly out of the
solar system very very similar to the
analogy of a roulette you know you have
the little ball going around the
roulette why doesn't it fly out of there
because it's got this this wall that's
preventing the little ball from flying
out and this is no different okay so
it's the roulette mechanism
and then uh what these people say is you
know when you show them this you say
well is this what you're saying you're
saying time is warped uh are you saying
there's a canvas there that comes
against the skin of the planet
you know is is our planet rolling or
scraping
around that depression is that why the
earth doesn't fly out because that's
what they've explained that's what they
illustrated that's what they told you
objectively
and they said bill you're not supposed
to take the analogy literally
and here this is what they show you okay
they show you this little
uh cartoon they said understanding
gravity
space time is like a rubber sheet
massive objects distort the sheet and
wait
they distort it because they're pulled
down by what
and the teacher you know loses patience
space time is like the set of equations
for which any analogy must be an
approximation
wrong okay it's not that it's an analogy
you have to explain
the mechanism of why the earth doesn't
fly out of the solar system if you're
going to go in there say well there's a
depression and the earth rolls around it
and blah blah blah and then at the end
of your class you say oh by the way that
was only an analogy there is no
depression there is not nothing coming
up against the skin of the earth then
what have you said what is your
mechanism
okay so this is the issue these people
give you a two hour explanation they
show you the pictures they describe the
pictures they show you the whole works
they explain the mechanism he said okay
i understood it because you see all the
objects on the screen or wherever
and then they say oh by the way that
that depression that's not there it's
just an analogy
you're not supposed to take it literally
great
okay so here we have um
the earth
because you know you're saying okay but
they were able to explain many things
with this okay
for example certain orbits and so on
with these equations not explain them
but really describe them okay and the
questions
does the mechanism
that general relativity that mr einstein
proposed
is it rational
can you use this
to
simulate what's out there
and they say yeah it is because see we
were able to explain like in this this
all mentioned that he says that there's
no planet called vulcan that's close to
the sun you know somewhere between uh
mercury and the sun because they have to
try to explain the orbit of mercury and
leveria try to explain that and he could
he died he he thought there was a planet
there
which was later named vulcan
because he's the guy who discovered you
know the
neptune and so they said just like he
did that math and figured out neptune
maybe we can figure out
you know
what is it
that there's a little planet there that
we can't see very well that's between
the earth and the sun and he says thanks
to general relativity we didn't need
that planet we could explain the orbit
of um
mercury
uh
just with equations
and what he doesn't understand this
fellow and 99 of humanity out there is
that mathematics is tautology
what they do is
they make an equation
that describes what they're observing
so it better be a tactology if the
equation is correct
it's just a tautology it means that
you're making a tailor-made equation so
that it fits the observation
and that's what einstein did with
mercury he just went in there put some
variables in there he says see if we put
it this this in this way
then we can we can explain
the orbit
and and what is einstein's equation for
mercury is that it's a point mass okay
to use that terminology it's a point
mass it describes the motion of a point
mass around the sun
that's what einstein's equation does
that's different than newton's which
said look there's two objects
and they attract
uh according to the inverse uh square of
the distance okay so so the notions are
different and in the case of minus it's
just a point mass that moves around the
sun and you're describing that path
so it is a tautology that's why it works
more or less you know maybe there's a i
think it's not perfect on the money but
it
pretty much resembles what mercury does
that's a description we still don't know
the mechanism why does mercury why does
mercury fly out of the solar system and
that's when they bring in the canvas
okay so what's the problem with the
canvas why is it irrational
okay why doesn't it explain it explains
mercury great i'll i'll concede
explains mercury rolling around the sun
what doesn't it explain which is 99 of
the other stuff and here is what it does
not
explain okay here we have uh the earth
and the moon rolling around the sun okay
so we have the the sun weighing down the
canvas okay
and then around that we have the earth
it also weighs its little canvas which
is rolling around the other canvas right
and the moon has to roll around the
canvas that the earth created okay so
far so good they're both
the can the two canvases the one for the
sun and the earth in fact even for the
moon they all point downwards okay
and we don't know why they point
downwards but we're not going to get
into that right now i just want you to
focus on the fact that
the um
uh
fish nets right the canvases okay
they're all uh parallel the one for the
earth the one for the moon and the one
for the sun they're all pretty much
parallel they're in the same direction
okay
what's the problem with this well the
problem with this is here okay
here you have the earth on the upper
right and that's correct they all are
parallel with the
ecliptic essentially right in other
words the canvas there matches the one
the canvas of the sun
but that doesn't happen with uranus and
it's big moon uh oberon okay oberon goes
uh
around the equator of
uranus but uranus is on its side uranus
uh twirls towards the sun all these are
views from the sun by the way okay so
you have um
oberon the biggest moon of uranus and
it's going towards in the direction of
the sun over the head
of uh uranus which is on its side it's
eq in other words oberyn's running
around its equator the north south is in
the east-west direction
okay so jupiter is on its side and it
has to be pushing the canvas towards the
side i chose one side it could be
towards the other side but it doesn't
matter it would point east in this case
or it could point west
in order for oberon to
orbit the
uranus the way it does
okay so we have a problem because the
earth weighs it downwards and the moon
weighs our moon weighs it down in other
words because they all are parallel with
the sun weighing no cannabis downwards
but uh oberon and uh uranus
falsify that
you know oberon uh twirls towards the
sun and so does uh uranus it's north and
south pole or sideways and what happens
with uh pluto and with sharon it's the
biggest moon well again you see there it
forms a bullseye pattern as seen from
the sun
okay so
pluto would have to uh push the canvas
outwards or inwards towards the sun in
order for sharon to orbit the way it
does you know in a bullseye pattern as
seen from the sun
so so the problem with einstein's
explanation is that it cannot explain
these three different mechanisms
you know with its canvas analogy
you know how do you explain it with a
with a canvas analogy if if the uh sun
weighs it downwards why would ju why
would uh uranus uh push the camera
sidewards and why would uh
pluto push it outwards
that's the issue and here let me um
let me uh
bring this
other give me a second here
this is a summary of what einstein's
theory is
his explanation his physical
interpretation of how these moons work
okay you see the sun waves the canvas
downwards you can see the white arrows
in below each one of the suns there okay
in the case of the earth no problem
everybody points downwards
in the case of uh uranus
it has to push the canvas sidewards in
order for oberon to
twirl around the canvas the roulette
mechanism
over the
top and towards the sun
and in the case of pluto
pluto would have to push it outwards or
inwards towards the sun in order for
sharon to twirl around in the direction
in which it does
so
einstein's theory does not work his
explanation does not work for a
three-body system
okay
and so here they have all these
tests of relativity that you'll find out
there in uh the wikipedia and they say
all these confirm relativity
general relativity okay
and maybe they should include you know
the
uh one is
i mean there's several i mean i'm just
pointing to one problem there which is
you know in the direction in which the
moons orbit
and einstein cannot explain that with
his
um
you know with his mechanism the
mechanism that he proposes for gravity
he cannot explain it a three-body system
okay so this is the issue and they
should include that see they never
include that within the
failures of general relativity they say
everything's been confirmed
you know and uh they
what are you gonna confirm for a black
hole zero dimensional nothing
what confirmation do you have there
you know what proof do you have
that there is a zero dimensional
matter less meaning massless
entity out there that's moving stars
around
dark matter
what have you confirmed about dark
matter
that there there's this invisible
variable that you put in an equation
and that you're looking for now in the
night sky
again all these are failures of general
relativity and nobody mentions that they
just
mention stuff that they measure and they
say oh uh we've proven everything in
fact they put detection of black holes
they show that ridiculous picture that
they
published and uh they got so many kudos
for
okay so um what's the underlying problem
of all this well the underlying problem
is that mathematical physics mathematics
does not use physical objects
and why don't they use objects well
because the mathematicians never defined
what an object is they have no use for
objects they only deal with equations
with behaviors and they don't care about
you know
objects they they do not care about
simulating things
with objects
and you can see where the problem is if
you go through the literature
any literature scientific so-called
scientific literature out there like i
do you know read papers
and what you will never find
or rarely is
i think almost never is a picture
here we have physics which should be a
discipline that should be full of
pictures you should have all these
pictures showing
mechanisms and so on and you go to these
so-called scientific literature and all
you find is equations you'll never find
a picture
why because it's
um
outside of their uh
job descriptions it's below their pay
grade to put pictures
in a uh
in a in an article
in a paper
and so this is where the problem is you
know physics uh we say it's causes and
mechanisms
the only way you can explain a cause or
a mechanism is if you have objects
because you have to simulate it with
some kind of object you got to show us
the mechanism
what mechanism
mechanism are you going to show if you
just put an equation what have you shown
okay you haven't shown a mechanism all
you have is a description a mathematical
description of you know something you
measured
you know but never never an explanation
of what caused that to happen that's the
issue
and so no uh physic the language of
physics is not mathematic mathematics
okay if
uh physics has to do with explanations
of mechanisms
and if it does then the language of
physics is illustration you have to
illustrate you have to illustrate the
singularity at the beginning of time big
bang
you have to illustrate dark matter and
show us how
it produces this mass that in other
words how does it keep that
star in the outside from going faster
you can't just say there's more mass
there because that's at this just as a
description
you haven't told me the mechanism what
causes it to go faster all you have is a
description of the fact that you know
there's more mass and according to the
equation it should go faster that's all
you've told me you haven't told me
anything about what is the mechanism in
fact they used newtonian uh
law for that you know
the gravitational law and newton said
you know
fingo non hypothesis in other words he
said i have
no i propose i have no
hypothesis no theory he had no
explanation for how that works
okay
okay so um
you need objects you need objects to
explain a mechanism and i'll give you an
example here okay
um
i need to explain to you
how the steam engine works you know a
long time ago
uh should be straightforward okay and
here it is i illustrate it for you okay
so that you can understand the mechanism
just by watching the movie
and here it is okay feed coal into the
furnace steam pushes the piston upwards
okay
introduce cold water and the piston
comes downwards now how difficult can
that be
anyone who watches this should say okay
i understand how the steam engine works
okay why it goes up and down because you
have that furnace at the bottom
steam pushes it upwards cold water
pushes it downwards
okay straight forward
did i need any mass
do i need to know how much energy do i
need to know mass or field or
or any of those parameters do i need to
know force no i'm just trying to figure
out what the mechanism is
and a 10 year old can tell you what the
mechanism is here you know he pushes it
up cold water pushes it down we're done
see how easy it was no math no no
nothing
that's what we want for gravity okay we
want an explanation like this a baby one
one that a ten-year-old can understand
what did i say say if you can't explain
it to a ten-year-old you don't know it
well enough or you don't know it at all
find one says something similar
or to a barmaid
okay so this is the issue the issue is
we want an explanation for what causes
the pen to go down
if that's science we haven't made any
progress in the last two and five
hundred years and we also need proposed
irrationalities in the last 200 years
opposite of what this fellow said okay
okay so here i'm going to show you a
little picture which i put in in the uh
science series
okay and
i want you to tell me objectively okay
what caused the window to break okay see
if you can figure it out i mean this is
difficult i know for some of you who are
not used to seeing images watching
movies it's very hard on your eyes or
whatever okay so here it is
so you have to tell me what caused
the window to break
here it is again just in case you missed
it
felix revolves it and throws it in
looks like
i think anyone on the planet would say
that a horseshoe
went through the window that's what
broke the glass
okay was it difficult one more time just
in case you missed it okay
now
this is what we call objectivity
i should get every person on the planet
who is more or less sane right
and um and ask them how did the window
break
and the person should say
that window that specific window person
should say you know horseshoe went
through the window broke the window
i'm not asking them anything about mass
and force and energy
whether he ate an ice cream i'm not
asking
stuff out of the ordinary i'm asking how
did the window break objectively what
did you see
every person should answer the same
thing
that's known as objective
and why we could see him because we
could see every single object
in the movie we could see the horseshoe
we could see the glass we could see you
know felix waving this horseshoe around
the horseshoe goes through the window
and breaks it
every person on earth should answer the
same thing anyone who doesn't has a
mental problem
what did this person answer
this is this is what he answered
let me put this up here
he said no one can objectively tell you
what happened there
especially seeing as they're just
cartoons
i couldn't believe his answer
so if i asked a 10 year old you know
what are you seeing there uh 10 year old
uh
what's happening there
and i think if i go to kindergarten
all the kids would say well bugs bunny
jumped or dived
you know he dove
into a rabbit hole that's what they
would say that's what you're staring at
that's objectively what's there
but he says he can't tell me objectively
what's there because it's a cartoon
that was his answer i couldn't believe
it
okay
but you see what kind of people you're
dealing with
either they're making themselves hard to
catch or they don't want to be
you know caught in their lies or in
their contradictions
so they say even more dumb things like
you know
i can't tell you because it's a cartoon
i can't tell you why the window broke i
can't tell you
uh that
uh what is it bugs
uh dove into his
his uh hole because it's a cartoon
and this is the problem with these
people
okay so now someone comes to you okay
someone comes to you he's a religious
folk someone from the
uh traditional religions
and he says
i've got a theory of gravity
okay what's your theory of gravity
it says here
i'm saying that angels
mediate gravity
i say that angels carry astronauts to
earth they uh force
angels they are here they force the pen
to fall and so
on so i'm a little skeptical
i'd have to see it
okay i've illustrated it for you here it
is i'm going to show you okay and so
here he puts this up there for you okay
so that you can verify what he's saying
the mechanism and here you have the
angel carrying
the you know astronaut to earth he says
that's how gravity works according to me
and you might go in there and say well
you know i don't believe in your theory
you know what what experiments have you
run you know i don't believe in angels i
don't even believe in god you know so
you know i think you're wrong
you know have you done any experiment
what's the equation uh can you show me
something
wrong questions
wrong question the person is saying
giving you a mechanism
he's telling you a mechanism of how he
thinks what he proposes of how gravity
works
we're not asking you to believe in his
theory
we're not asking you to what's the
evidence how many people have voted for
your theory we don't care about any of
that
we want to understand what's in his mind
as far as what he proposes for the
mechanism of gravity
and there he shall he's saying
angels carry it down to earth
and the question is did you understand
the mechanism that he's proposing
that's the question
and if you didn't understand it and you
say well
you know it's just a cartoon anyways
well then you got a problem you got a
mental problem okay you got a mental
problem because the question is do you
understand the mechanism that he's
proposing
that's the question that's what's before
us we're not talking about evidence
we're not talking about who believes in
it we're
looking at the mechanism okay so now
there's another fellow he comes up and
he says look i've got a
theory of gravity
okay what's your theory
well i say that all atoms in the
universe are interconnected
and uh so every atom from the earth is
connected to the astronaut
and so as he approaches the earth he
ropes in this case right they fan out
all these elongated entities
fan out and he accelerates ever at a
faster rate
so he goes faster faster faster we call
that acceleration and that's the
acceleration of gravity
well can you illustrate
that mechanism for me
yeah sure
and here the fella goes in there and he
illustrates it for you and he says here
it is okay
he didn't draw all the uh
elongated objects there because it would
be a gazillions he just drove
you know illustrated a few so that you
can understand the mechanism of what is
bringing the
uh astronaut to earth why he falls to
earth and not to you know to outer space
why because the earth is very close by
again and consistent consistent with
newton's equation so we're all safe
there okay so the fellow falls to earth
the astronaut falls the earth because
every atom in his body is bound to every
atom that comprises the earth
that's the theory okay and the question
is
did you understand the theory
and that guy says well i don't believe
in your theory
i i don't see any ropes or
or
anything you know uh between any two
atoms i can't touch them
so where did you come up with this
and why can't i touch them and so on you
know and so the issue is did you
understand the
mechanism that's the only question the
question did you understand the
mechanism
and the guy said well no i don't
understand because it's a cartoon
okay what are you gonna do the guy
doesn't understand because it's a
cartoon we're asking him to understand
why the window broke he doesn't
understand against a cartoon he doesn't
understand why
uh that bugs dove into his hole because
you know uh it's just a cartoon
he doesn't understand that the angel
carried the astronaut to earth because
that's just a cartoon and he doesn't
understand the ropes because
he says that's a cartoon
and so
you know we're talking about mechanisms
here and he doesn't understand it yet he
understood probably
uh i think you know the steam engine
and you say where did you understand
that that was a cartoon too
yeah but that's real and i prove it and
i've got evidence and everybody voted
for it
so he believes on the basis of authority
because that's a cartoon too that was a
drawing
and so this is the issue the issue is
people are confusing belief
with objectivity what we have in front
of us if i ask every person on earth
what did you just see
they should all say any rational human
being should say the astronaut every
atom in his body was tied to every atom
on earth and so he fell because
you know the ropes got closer to the
earth now maybe they're elastic we don't
understand that yet there are other
problems but the issue is
they should be able to give you in
general terms that the astronaut fell to
earth because he's every atom in his
body is bound to every atom on earth
he's tied to the earth
that's the mechanism now we can go into
more detail later on but the issue is
we're talking about mechanisms here
whether you understand the mechanism
propose if you don't well we have to say
a little more maybe so that you
understand it better
but to say well i can't understand
because it's a cartoon
well not very smart
and and you say well where'd you get
that anyways i mean where'd you come up
with all this nonsense uh about you know
uh all atoms being interconnected and so
on well here it is okay here's for those
who want proof and evidence we don't
deal with this in science but here you
have proof evidence authority all the
stuff that you always wanted okay
here you have uh mr richard muller
professor at berkeley says so for
example if you have the earth there's a
big mass here and you have you with your
little mass here
every atom on earth is pulling on every
atom of you
you're also pulling on it the amazing
thing about gravity is that it goes
right through things
okay
so yeah if every atom on you of you is
pulling on every atom on earth and vice
versa it means every atom of you is
connected physically connected to every
atom on earth because otherwise you're
introducing black magic
you're saying that
when adam pulls on you
but there's no connection no physical
entity between you that's what you're
saying
okay
so
this is the issue the issue is mechanism
uh this person you know this individual
apparently does not understand that he
thinks that science is about just math
and authority and just believing in what
the
people in cambridge and oxford and
harvard and cal tech
you know just feed him
and hopefully not hopefully science is
about like what he did here
questioning uh the instructor or the
theorist or whoever question them and
the question did he ever question
his
instructors his teachers or what he read
did he ever question that and or did he
just accept and say well you know black
holes have been proven so yeah
i'll accept that and i'll accept dark
matter and i'll accept dark energy and
that a particle can be at two places at
once and blah blah blah blah blah why
because it's being fed to him as proof
and truth and fact
that's the only reason he believes in it
he has no argument i mean he could just
as well raise the arguments he raised in
my videos
against those are those uh theories why
did he ever do that
and i'm i'm almost sure he did because
you know you find people like joe rogan
and so on they they interview all these
people uh the celebrities of math
and
they tell me there's several universes
and
uh the particles come out of nothing
and we have all these black holes and
dark matter out there
and he never questioned it's like oh
okay that's nice that's interesting then
he brings another celebrity who tells
them the same thing
and they all just accept it and accept
it and accept it and accept it no one
questions it what do you mean black hole
what do you mean that particles can come
out of the void what do you mean that a
particle can be in two places at once
nobody questions that
they just accept it because it comes
through the
channel of
authority that's what it's called
okay let me get on to a couple questions
and then uh open the floor for rational
questions if you're if you put bs there
i'll skip over your questions okay so
think of good questions okay put me on
the spot that's your job okay my job is
to answer
okay fellow says here he says uh
clickbait he says uh you
uh your title quantum tunneling is easy
to understand the false bait title is
something that should be addressed with
youtubers and embarrassed off this the
platform and this title of yours
included
you didn't explain anything the same way
that they didn't observe their findings
i came here hoping you might have an
explanation that was better than those
just repeating what they were
conditioned to repeat on this topic i
didn't get that i hate bogus titles on
videos
okay he was talking about that video
i've got the link there and quantum
probably is easy to understand that's
what i call it well the first thing i
have to tell this uh fellow is that um
you know i don't do click bait at all i
mean
you should have figured out by now that
i don't get that many views
i mean you know i'm not in the business
of click baiting no i put a title either
to embarrass quantum mechanics general
relativity strength theory mathematical
physics in general or sometimes it's
appropriate to the subject matter that
i'm dealing with in this case it was
appropriate as i saw it okay not for
click baiting but so that people
understand that the easy it's easy to
understand quantum mechanics it's just
nonsense that's what you have to
understand
and i talked about entanglement and
other things and yes um i explained in
that video
exactly what i was talking about so i
don't know where this fella didn't catch
that i don't know if you didn't watch
the whole video but i watched it the
other day to see if i missed something
no i think i explained very well
the issue of entanglement and some other
problems with quantum mechanics
okay same fellow but this is another
question he raised and this one
got to me a little deeper
okay he says the following says if you
can take that negative energy
you have for the system and refocus it
from trying to embarrass or make
examples of the conditioned thinkers out
there to ideas of in or individuals that
are breaking outside the box would be so
much better than just
downing and negatively bashing those
ideas or individuals you don't agree
with
don't show me just the parts you find as
irrational point me to ways uh places or
individuals that will help rationalize
some of nature's mysteries
okay uh some of his uh points are well
taken my son ans he also
beats me up sometimes saying uh
you beat up people
uh yeah i say that i don't beat them up
i
treat them with the respect that they
deserve that's different you know i
don't insult them i'm just treating them
with the respect that they have earned
and
uh yeah but this is my challenge for
this fellow this gentleman okay this is
what i suggest here's a
thought because i talked a lot about you
know what's happening in the
mathematical world in the so-called
scientific world out there all the
censorship
all the um
the fact that we don't have a level
playing field the fact that they um
dismiss all people who disagree with
them
as cranks and crackpots they have all
these
things that they put in place
to
belittle anyone who questions general
relativity and quantum mechanics
primarily and also string theory and so
you know um
you know i have something i have a
reason
for doing my stuff i've been at this for
25 years
and i received a lot of punishment over
the years i've got very thick skin by
the way so if anyone says something bad
about my mother you know it doesn't hurt
me at all i can sleep well at nights
anyways but this is what i suggest this
is the deal i'll make with this
gentleman okay here it is okay this is a
fellow known as uh john bias
he's joan baez's cousin by the way
singer
and
i'm going to look at points 11 and 20
here
number 11 says 10 points for each claim
that quantum mechanics is fundamentally
misguided without good evidence and 10
points for each favorable comparison of
yourself to einstein or claim that
special or general relativity are
fundamentally misguided he created the
crackpot index
the crackpot index is at that location
there at the university of riverside
university of california at riverside
it's been there for over 20 years
and its
riverside is a university partly
maintained by
public funds
so here's my challenge to you
i want you to write a letter okay
instead of complaining against me write
a letter to the university of riverside
and get this nonsense that bias put up
there on taxpayers money and maintaining
there for 20 years see if you can get it
out of there when you get it out of
there i'll make sure that i never bash a
mathematician again
and then i want to point out to number
19 there 10 points for arguing that
while you well a current
well-established theory predicts
phenomena correctly it doesn't explain
why they occur or fails to provide a
mechanism
so yes uh here's the problem uh
mathematical physics does not provide
mechanisms okay
and so we have a big problem here
because that is what science is about
that is what physics is about mechanisms
and that's what these people are really
trying to find out because they say
we're trying to explain gravity but they
never explain that they only describe it
and so you say you know why does this
pencil this pen fall
to the ground
why not why does it fall to the ceiling
and they cannot answer that what they do
is describe it mathematically and say
well there's more mass
that's a description you haven't
explained the matter what does mass have
to do with anything how does mass pull
on the pen pen is real mass is a concept
how does mass the concept or gravity the
concept pull on the pen what is the
mechanism what came in contact with with
the skin of the pen that's what you got
to answer
and if you say nothing then you're doing
black magic and if you do
uh
concepts such as mass and field and all
in wave and all that nonsense
and then it's even worse than uh black
magic then it's totally irrationality
and that's what we have in the last 150
years just irrational explanation for
how the pen
you know what caused the pen to fall to
the floor
so uh yeah we call it irrational here
are the
criteria for irrationality okay
creating concepts as objects reification
we call it congruentization
if you treat a field
you use the word field or the word
energy is physical objects you are in
your rational individual you have an
irrational theory because a theory is a
mechanism and you're trying to explain
the mechanism using a concept you're
saying the concept pulled on an object
that's what you're saying
okay those that's the primary one
there's a couple more there i'll let you
later on read it
let me move on here we'll move on to
another fellow here
says the following
[Music]
says
we were dealing with time last time this
fellow addresses this issue which is
good okay he says a second is a
measurement of time
okay good it's a measurement right time
whatever time is
he said time is change or the interval
of change
and there's only one motion that repeats
predictably is needed to have a measure
of time
well there we have
a single ball
what is the time
the only way you're going to figure out
time is if you have a clock or something
else that's moving and you compare that
motion against the motion of the ball
if the ball is the only object that god
made in the universe and then he
disappears so there's only one object or
that's the only object that appeared in
the universe a ball
and it's moving
through space just the ball moving
through space
what's time
what's the time is it ten o'clock
no motion is a synonym of change change
in motion are exact synonyms that's why
you cannot define the word motion using
the word change
so you cannot say motion is the change
and
you're already screwed because change is
motion motion is changed you can't use
the word change can't use a synonym
to define a word so you can't use the
word change and that's motion but time
is not just motion and time is not just
change there's a little more than change
there you have change you have motion
okay
so uh where's the where's the time
for time you need another motion
okay so this is the issue no time is not
just change time is not just motion
okay
same fellow i think uh says up there
1967 the 13th general conference on
weights and measures
provisionally find the second as nine
blah blah blah blah cycles of the cesium
133 atom okay
atomic time clocks are the most precise
time keepers in the world
well this poor fellow i guess is not
aware but there was an experiment there
are several experiments but i'm just
going to mention one of them probably
the first one or the most important one
and it's known as the have the keating
experiment
and it says was the test was a test of
the theory of relativity in october 1971
these two fellows took four cesium
beam atomic clocks aboard commercial
airliners they flew twice around the
world first eastward then westward you
see that at the bottom right
and compare the clocks against others
that remained at the united states naval
observatory okay
when reunited the three sets of clocks
were found to disagree with one another
that's how accurate the atomic locks
were
they flew just a little height above sea
level and they were completely
inaccurate and this spell says
uh well let's look at it again it says
it's the the most precise time keepers
in the world
and no no uh let's make sure we
understand the most precise time keeper
in the world is the orbit of the earth
around the sun
and the reason for that is
that you know the earth doesn't deviate
from its uh orbit in any significant way
uh
for eons so you can pretty much count on
that it's not perfect but
it's on the money pretty much you know
it goes around and around always isn't
why because
the earth doesn't scrape its shoulder
against space because space is nothing
unlike in relativity where it's a little
ball that it's got this white stuff
outside that nobody knows what it is
nobody wants to define but space in
rational science
is nothing and nothing is that which
doesn't have shape
thing that which has shape nothing that
which doesn't have shape see how easy it
was anyways uh
the earth cannot scrape its uh shoulder
no friction there between the skin of
the earth and space
and so it rolls around the earth around
the sun regularly so that's the most
accurate clock that we have in our
region okay
now is it useful well it's useful to
determine what the year is okay
that's what it's useful for and this
will ask a question along those lines he
said look
a gravity clock meaning an hourglass in
a zero gravity environment is useless
yeah that wasn't the point that wasn't
the context the context is if you take a
destruction of general relativity which
is another
uh falsifying factor of general
relativity you take one
you know hourglass
okay
hourglass you take it out there to the
mountain okay
and you take and you leave one here at
sea level or you take one closer to
outer space you know not completely into
outer space
uh you just take it further out into the
sky
and it falls at a different rate
than the one on the ground
and it works in reverse to what general
relativity says what einstein said
it works exactly in reverse
it works faster close to the source of
gravity
and it works slower out there in space
or farther up in the sky
and eisen predicted that's the word they
used prediction
said it's different he came out with
this law that says all clocks in the
universe
you know uh working the opposite
direction that the clock and the ground
should uh work slower and the one in the
sky should go faster and that's not the
case here you have a gravitational clock
which is what a
hourglass is a sand clock right and it
works faster close to sea level and
slower up on the mountain
we're done you know it just kills
relativity because relativity is based
on that premise on that
supposedly uh
what is it uh
supposition
you know so
if if they start on the wrong foot of
course the foundation of general
relativity this foundation is wrong it's
irrational
okay and here we have uh another issue
says
says a body takes time to decompose okay
and he says
the colony of microbes i guess he's
going over some biolog biology stuff
here colony of microbes and worms
feasting on it the time this takes
doesn't depend on temporal particles
it depends on the environment
okay i don't know what temporal
particles are i guess cronons
hitting them right
physical reactions not time
uh time is not a thing it's a concept
yeah correct but then he says when time
successfully changes the physical
properties of objects time changes the
physical properties of objects
what is he talking about he just said
that time doesn't hit anything there are
no particles of time now he's talking
about things a thing called time that's
hitting
you know the
properties of objects right and the
correct characteristics of a physical
reaction then yes time is a real
physical thing there is no speculation
about it the experiment is there
so this guy went around in circles can
you learn anyone anything from this
fellow this poor fellow he says it's a
concept then he says it's an object it's
both
so you learn a lot with these people
they go around in circles and just say
nonsense that's all it is
okay uh fellow says i think it's the
same follows says
maybe not premise one science attempts
to help people understand the universe
premise two some people are bad at
understanding things
conclusion science fails to explain
the universe no problems in logic i see
here
well uh yeah he's got it all wrong
because science is not about
understanding that's where he's got it
wrong so here's the answer understand is
under receiving end
someone can explain rationally and the
other guy is uh you know down's patient
he he won't understand what he said what
this guy said
so understanding is not science
explanation is science okay so that's
where his premises fail okay
so just keep that in mind here we have
another fellow and he says the strange
thing here is that you seem to be
challenging the definition and purpose
of science
yeah not of science but of mathematical
science okay
the religion of mathematics that's
different in science that's what i'm
challenging and yet you end the video by
agreeing with the current d
definition and purpose
i have no idea what this guy is talking
about what he understood he probably
didn't understand much and here is the
purpose of the current definition of
science in other words mathematical
physics is to know to believe because
that's what knowledge is
knowledge is belief okay
uh i covered that the other day okay i'm
saying that knowledge
according to plato is justified true
belief when you know something it's
because you believe it
and if someone later on shows that you
did not know it that you that your
knowledge was false and does it
retroactively convert to a belief is
that what you had
so we have a problem and word knowledge
is a synonym of belief there is no
difference between knowledge and belief
and the purpose of genuine science is to
explain objectively in the case of
physics a mechanism and how you
concluded the video ends accepting what
it began attacking is beyond the
rational mind
i have no idea what this poor fellow
you'd understood
but see they don't clarify because if if
they would clarify in detail if he's
going to take the trouble
to explain in detail uh then you would
think that you know uh then you would
have something to address you would say
okay i understand when he was attacking
what he was referring to but he just you
know blurts out a statement i mean if
he's got a right like he wrote a long
piece there he's going to write a lot at
least have the decency of putting
exactly what you're referring to but he
just makes
a statement saying well you
you ended up concluding the same thing
you started
attacking
how did you conclude that give me an
example tell me what you're what's going
through your tiny little brain
okay
and i think you're saying the same
though he goes in and he says no let's
just believe but belief has more than
just one definition oh it does okay
let's find out it shouldn't have because
in science we only have one definition
per word right but knowledge is not part
of science so it doesn't matter to us so
he says a religious belief for example
is one where you know something to be
true despite complete lack of any
supporting evidence it is unjustified a
scientific belief is one where we are
only able to come to conclusion based on
the information we currently hold one
that may be supported by literally
billions of pieces of evidence and as
more information is gathered the belief
alters it is justified
all he did was repeat
plato
he said nothing new
belief according to plato was just
unjustified belief and knowledge is
justified belief justified true belief
that's that's what it is so all he said
he went through this whole thing when i
had already stated all that you know so
no there are no
two definitions of uh knowledge okay or
a belief uh we have belief which is
unjustified belief and knowledge which
is justified belief and so here's my
answer to justified belief okay here it
is okay
knowledge is justified opinion belief is
unjustified opinion
and who cares if it is justified to you
because again if you what is your
justification turns out that
justification is also a belief
so i don't care about if you if your
belief is justified or not that the
justification is also a belief
it's an opinion
and who determines justification doesn't
a believer in god believe
that his belief is justified
okay or unjustified
so yeah i mean uh the justification
itself is a belief and opinion so it
doesn't matter that's where plato was
wrong that it doesn't matter if you're
justified or unjustified
absolutely doesn't matter at all
it's belief either way
so there is only one definition of
knowledge and a belief and that is that
it's just a belief
whether it's justified or not is also
belief
belief over belief my belief is is uh
believable that's all you said
and the final issue here phil talks
about exists he says something cannot
exist unless it is explained
now any normal reasonable person would
laugh at you if you said that to them
yeah i agree
fortunately i don't say those things but
i don't know where he got this
maybe watch another movie i don't know
and yet you have uh said phrases that
mean the very thing several times in
your videos on gravity again where did
this guy i mean he concludes things and
wants to put words in my mouth
i mean if he would have put an example
that would have been great that way i
have something to challenge her to
address but just making a blank
statement like that i mean why does he
even take the trouble to write
you would think if he's going to take
the trouble of writing something at
least
put what you're referring to i'll be
glad to address it
i have nothing to address he just
put words in my mouth said oh you said
it i said what
okay let me go with the question see if
anyone asked a rational question
you can see we had quite a little bit of
irrational people here okay let's find
out we have someone rational today
okay lots of comments here
one guy says who's definition your own
made up crap i don't know if you
answered me or someone else but uh yeah
it doesn't matter who whose definition
it is i don't care if it's mine or
someone else's
again the definition is one that you
step into the ring and defend if you
cannot defend your definition well then
you have a problem don't you you can say
well i believe in my definition anyways
yeah okay fine
you know you can go with whatever
definition but don't come into science
in science you got to defend your
definition and you can't say i found it
in the dictionary
so
so you found it in the dictionary and
the dictionary is never wrong okay in
fact it's never right
if you find it in addiction 99.99
of the time it's wrong it's not
scientific that's what i mean you can't
use those definitions in science because
a scientific definition is one that you
can use consistently it's objective okay
if you can use it consistently you don't
have to worry about uh you know
having a challenge to your definition
it's only people whose religion falls
down the drain by the wayside you know
those are the ones that complain about
definitions and they oh you're doing
semantics
yeah
because your virgin was raped that's why
okay another foul says does he
says who is defining electrical as
electron beads what do you mean
everybody defines it as electron beads
uh i mean what is the um
uh photoelectric effect electron beads
you know being pushed by photons photon
beads so you have photon ton beads
pushing electron beads out of their
orbits i mean what is an electron
is an electron a bead that rolls around
the nucleus if not please draw your atom
so next time you know illustrate your
atom you know i'm or point to it
somewhere on the internet i'll be glad
to address it just show me your your
atom with that electron i want to see
where where you're going to put the
electron what you're going to illustrate
and you know you can upload an image and
you know point to the url or if there's
one on the internet that you know about
just point to the url i'll be glad to
address it
okay so i need to see your electron
before you talk about
electron beads but that is what the
establishment has in fact the electric
universe also goes with electron beads
everybody uses beads i mean what do you
see just look up a gif or a uh on
youtube uh how electricity flows and
what you'll see is little balls that's
how they illustrate everybody else's
wrenches the same way electron beads
moving along the wire if you have a
different version
you know be glad to hear it okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
in physics an object is an identifiable
collection of matter which may be
constrained by an identifiable boundary
and may move as a unit blah blah blah
blah blah okay yeah
a boundary is known as shape
essentially but uh you know you you have
um uh euclid and he said he defined what
a figure is and he said if that's what
has a boundary and then uh
in what was it uh definition 13 the one
before it says what's a boundary what
boundary is the
cover of a figure
so he just went around in circles so you
got to define these terms you got to
know what a boundary is
boundary of what
you know what is a boundary
a uh is the boundary of a square a
boundary
uh
you know of a circle is that a boundary
are we going to consider that a boundary
as well a perimeter or whatever
so yeah we need to know what the word
boundary means when you say that but
anyways as says it's a collection of
matter it feels already there collection
of anything is not an object collection
is meriology uh collection of tables is
not an object
a collection of uh atoms you know gas
uh
the gas as a whole is an object because
it does have shape but if you're going
to define gas as a collection of
atoms then it's not an object that's a
definition okay
objects we point to uh
concepts we define okay so no
okay
a field is an energy's interaction with
materials
so a field is interaction if a field is
an interaction then it's not a physical
object okay because if we're talking
about an interaction it's like saying
um
you know a boxer
and he punches the other boxer and he
says what's a what's a
a punch well punch is an interaction
so there's no physical object called
punch punch is the verb
which interacted you know one hand with
with the skin of the the other guy's
face you know that's called an
interaction so interaction is not a
physical object you can't say that a
field is a physical object
which is good uh i mean yeah field is an
interaction that's why field is not a
physical object
not for the purposes of science
okay uh phil says
mass and weight are not the same measure
in engineering science physics well
whether they're
uh
same measure in
in disciplines related to mathematics we
don't care
what we care about is you know from the
physics point of view what is the
difference between mass and weight
and the way we determine mass is by
weighing it so and we end up with
kilograms which is the way we uh
identify weight
and people say well that's in ordinary
speech not in
science not in physics not in
mathematical physics
well the question is we've never been
able to isolate mass from weight okay
mass
we would have to count atoms and express
the result in terms of quantity of atoms
we do neither we do not count atoms
and we do not express mass in number of
units number of atoms number of hydrogen
atoms for example we do not express it
that way we always express it in terms
of a measure not in terms of counting
and measuring and counting are totally
different counting you count one two
three four five
and you would say well this thing has a
trillion atoms that would be the mass of
that thing that's how we do it we say
weighs one kilogram
which is a measure and which is the same
as weight
we have no way of isolating mass from
weight because we don't count atoms so
if you take whatever object a piece of
steel from from the earth
to the moon
and weigh it there after you wait it
here you say well they weigh differently
yeah and the mass of them is also
differently
because the way we determine mass but is
by way we put them on a scale or
whatever and we weigh it so now we never
express mass that i've seen i've never
seen anyone express mass in a quantity
of atoms
i've never heard anyone say look uh a
telephone uh weighs
or has a mass of a gazillion atoms never
heard that okay
okay
see we have
zero volume is called vacuum yes
correctly that's what a black hole is
zero
okay
give me a second here
hmm
well lots of comments but no questions
just debates among the listeners there
primarily
i said squares are in your mind and are
not an object
well you have to define object in order
to know whether a square is an object or
not and if you define it as that which
has shape well the square has shape and
so does a uh
cube so
you have to define uh the word object in
order to find out whether a square is an
object or not you just follow the
definition and if you have a different
definition of the word object than me no
problem but then you got to defend it
you got to get inside the ring and fight
for your definition okay you can't just
say well that's my definition okay yeah
you can define anything you want but you
can't defend it because you're afraid
for someone to tear it to pieces that's
the problem
and believe me if you want to debate the
word object you came to the right person
i know what a thing is in fact i'm more
proud of my
definition of the word object and the
fact that i discovered how important
defining the word object is for the
purposes of physics and science i'm more
proud of that than of my rope
i would put that on top if i'm going to
heaven i'm going to him because of the
word object not because of the rope okay
okay
entanglement says the universe is
connected no entanglement i don't know
if you say no or yes but no entanglement
says the universe is connected don't
know if he says yes or no okay
okay one fellow says a wave is an action
verb what's waving yeah
you have to identify the thing that's
waving okay for that you need to define
what a thing is hopefully it's not that
which you can see or touch because we
can't see or touch the mediator of light
or gravity or any of those
space time is a field and that is an
object well we just covered that no
space timing i don't know about space
and but field is not an object okay and
the space time is a field then it's not
an object either
there's a physics definition of time
change or the interval that change
occurs yeah no that's like i said you
know uh time is not change it's a little
more than change motion is changed but
not time okay they're not synonyms and i
cover that
that fellow says there's something about
shape but
i guess only he understands himself
square is only in your mind yeah it
doesn't matter uh square you can uh i
can draw it out here so you can put a
square out here as well we call that a
square we point to it
and again you don't even have to draw it
like i said you have a cube right
if i point it at you in the right way
you see only one face okay
assuming that we're a perfect cube right
and i put it to you and say
square
see how easy is it it was a square is is
the face of a cube
okay now is it a perfect one no it's a
simulation of the ideal
square okay
but the point is that if you see a shape
if if god
with all his powers right because god is
all-powerful remember uh you don't like
god maybe you like the devil okay we'll
do the devil and he only he takes his
magic wand and he goes abracadabra and
puts a square in the middle of space
okay because he's got the power
he's got the power to do that so he puts
a square in the middle of space that's
all he created he's just starting out
he's starting out small
so he puts a square or a circle in the
middle of a space
well that's a that's a square it's got
shape
and it's outside his mind he put it out
there in space for you to see
so he's got that power he he can put a
square out there okay
and you see it and you say okay that's a
square
i mean if uh
now that we all know what a square is
out there you know uh
you can close your eyes and
visualize a square
and what are you going to visually what
do you think you're seeing you know when
you close your eye you see a square
or a circle or
a triangle
it's no biggie
you know so
uh it's a
a square is just a side
of a cube that's what it is and a circle
is the perimeter of a sphere and so on
down triangle maybe the the side of a
pyramid of course we're talking about
ideal
uh geometries
but you know god is all-powerful he can
make a triangle in the middle of space
and that's how i would present it to you
i would put a triangle out there in the
middle of space with space as the
backdrop you would see a shape
and i point to it and say triangle
and the e.t who's next to me he learned
the word triangle because he looks at
that he sees the triangle he says okay
that's a shape
that's a that's an object it's got shape
we're done let's see how easy it was
very easy really
okay
anyways we'll see you next time uh what
is it on sunday we'll see you then and
we'll continue with the
the series of this fellow and find out
uh
other arguments uh you know rejoinders
that i'm going to be bringing up uh to
counter his arguments okay so we'll see
you then we'll see you on sunday bye-bye